hey everyone its Johanna here are you a
late-night snack err do you stay up late
nights because your work demands it or
perhaps you are a student preparing for
an upcoming examination or it's a TV
show keeping you up well whatever your
reasons are late night snacking mainly
to regain and it can also sabotage your
weight loss effort
hence choosing the right snack is key to
satisfy your cravings or hunger without
packing on the high amount of calories
which mainly feel feeling bloated and
regretful in the morning so if you are a
late night snack err I want you to stick
to these three rules first your snacks
should be under 200 calories remember
this is a snack not a meal if you over
it especially late at night when we are
physically inactive those calories are
more likely to be stored as fat second
drink a glass of water first and wait
for at least 20 minutes before you start
stacking this will allow your brain to
register whether are you truly hungry or
are you just dehydrated
or bored third if you feel the urge to
snack out of boredom then ask yourself
why am I still up so late at night
shouldn't I be in bed lack of sleep can
also sabotage your weight loss effort so
to help you with your snacking here are
my top 10 healthy and nutritious
late-night snacks which are also under
100 calories my number one choice has to
be my favorite frozen yogurt ice cream
instead of the typical creamy high
calories high fat ice cream this
healthier alternative is light low in
calories and satisfied my ice cream
cravings to make them I've used 50 gram
of sliced bananas 150 gram of frozen
strawberries or any other fruits of your
choice 200 gram of Greek although fat
plain yogurt and 1 tbsp of goji berries
blend all the ingredients until thick
and smooth
then place the mixture into six popsicle
mos freeze them overnight and you can
enjoy your guilt free ice cream
throughout the week and the best part is
each stick is only 40 calories so in
fact you can treat yourself to two
sticks this second stack is perfect for
a late night movie pop cards are
generally low in calories recording at
only 31 calories per cup this is of
course the no butter no sugar plain
popcorns so instead of buying ready
popcorns which are loaded with fat and
added sugar let's go back to the basic
and make our own healthy popcorns and
add our own flavors it is really simple
place cut a cup of popcorn kernels into
a microwave-safe bowl cover firmly
either with a lid or a plate you want to
make sure that there is no gap between
the bowl and plate microwave it for
about 5 minutes or until the popping
slows down be careful when removing from
the microwave as the dish is very hot
finally top it up with your own flavors
I've coated mine with honey allow them
to cool down and you have your healthy
movie snack ready to munch aged 2 cups
of serving with 1/2 a tbsp of honey is
only 94 calories stall the rest away in
a food container and you will always
have your healthy movie snacks for
emergency if you are truly hungry and
you want a bigger portion without adding
the extra amount of calories then a bowl
of warm soup is perfect at this time of
the night
avoid creamy ones and go for broth-based
soup which is lighter and easier to
digest and of course skip the noodles
and starchy cups to avoid bloating and
the extra calories which may be stored
as fat I've made my seafood vegetable
soup with 2 cups of vegetable broth 50
gram of green leafy vegetables and
carrots 1 ounce or 30 gram of prawns and
1 tbsp of goji berries this bowl which
looks like
Mill only has 93 calories so if you want
your Chinese takeaway make your own
vegetable soup instead we all know that
vegetables are healthy low in calories
keep you satisfied and perfect to be
eaten all day long so my next favorite
late-night snack is carrots and hummus
instead of buying the dips I have made
my own hummus the ingredients you'll
need are half a can of chickpeas washed
and drained cut a cup of Greek or plain
yogurt 1 clove of garlic minced half a
teaspoon of olive oil quarter teaspoon
of dried parsley and quantity spoon of
paprika place all the ingredients in to
food processor and process until you
have a smooth and creamy texture my
carrots and hummus is under 100 calories
you can always change the vegetables and
dips to your own taste if you are
working or studying late-night and you
need something to munch on to keep you
going try this out you can always make a
few containers store them in the fridge
and when you have the urge to munch you
have a healthy snack to turn to my next
quick easy and healthy snack to go for
is tuna sandwich crackers instead of
choosing bread which is more dense and
has more calories go for whole grain or
whole wheat crackers instead which
typically has about 35 calories each -
whole grain crackers spread with quater
can of tuna only has 100 calories this
is light high in protein and high in
complex carbs which can help to control
further cravings
most of us start our day with a bowl of
cereal or oatmeal and this can actually
be part of your healthy late night snack
I tend to have this myself as well at
times what you want to avoid is the
sugary cereals so go for smaller portion
go for a small bowl of whole grain or
whole wheat cereals to curb hunger for
instance one pane Weetabix with quarter
cup of semi skimmed milk only has ninety
eight point two five calories so you can
have your breakfast as your late-night
snack
if for some reason you crave muffins
cakes or banana why not try my zucchini
bread and banana muffin recipes instead
remember that all my recipes are
interchangeable so you can have them for
breakfast as your afternoon snack or
even late night snack more healthy and
light snacks perfect for the nighttime
include yogurt and fruits 100 gram of
low-fat yogurt with 1 TSP of raw honey
and quarter cup of strawberries only has
100 calories
hot chocolate my favorite you have seen
me drink this prior to bedtime a warm
glass of milk or hot chocolate will not
only help you sleep better it can also
reduce food cravings one cup of
unsweetened soy milk with one teaspoon
of cocoa powder only has about a 98
calories and of course you can choose to
sweeten it with honey or stevia I love
this other healthy late night snack
ideas include whole fruit nuts dry
fruits
healthy snack bar and even an egg what
you want to avoid is obviously takeaways
high-fat greasy food
caffeine energy drink alcohol and
starchy food which tends to be high in
calories in fact even all the healthy
foods should be consumed in moderation
to avoid slip in digestion bloating and
excess calories intake tackling late
night snacking and cravings is also
about being prepared the more healthy
snacks you have in a fridge the more
likely you are to reach for them instead
opting for the unhealthy options so the
more prepared you are the more likely
you will stick to your fitness goal the
question is are you a late-night snack
err for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you